a young man identifies himself as a wolf
so his family admits him to a center
where he will meet other people who
suffer from the same condition
today on cinema recapped i'll show you
wolf
the movie starts the boy named jacob
who's wandering through the forest but
in a very peculiar way since he's barely
wearing clothes and behaves like a wolf
this happens because in this world
there's a strange disease called species
dysphoria which makes people frequently
believe they're animals
in jacob's case he feels that he's a
wolf and behaves like one
we see jacob's parents say goodbye to
him since they've interned him in a
place that receives people with species
dysphoria to try and cure them and
remove those behaviors
during his first session at the clinic
jacob feels uncomfortable since he's
surrounded by strange people
they all introduce themselves he meets
dr angela who is the local psychologist
he also meets rufus who thinks he's a
german shepherd and judith who has a
tendency to behave like a bird and wears
a costume that makes her look like one
he also meets jeremy who believes he's a
squirrel this last one begins to cry
since he wants to be a rodent
while the doctor tries to calm him down
shortly thereafter we see them resting
in a room that has several things for
them to enjoy
rufus approaches jacob and tells them
that they're a family since they both
identify themselves as heard animals
at the same time a man starts to bother
a boy
rufus tells jacob that he's about to
leave since he's improved a lot that the
man is bothering the boy to cure him so
they must not intervene
at meal time rufus approaches jacob
again and tells him that since he is new
he is allowed to eat animal food and he
also asks him to pet him
but jacob just ignores him
rufus feels annoyed and barks at jacob
little then he starts eating the animal
food the doctor quickly picks him up and
tells him that she can't believe he's
doing that since he had improved a lot
later they take jacob rufus and jeremy
for a walk as they'll have a little
session with dr mann who demands jeremy
climb a tree like the squirrel he is
that tells him to do it with his claws
like a real rodent however the boy
breaks one of his nails so they take him
away to heal him
the doctor stays with jacob telling him
that if he's a wolf he must walk on four
legs and holds him to the ground to do
so
also he tells him to howl
but jacob says that he does not want to
be a wolf doctor man tells him not to
tell lies and demands that he howl like
the animal he is
but jacob doesn't obey
so the man congratulates him for putting
up with it and not behaving like an
animal the next day dr mann sits jacob
in front of another girl at the same
time he shows them a diary that he stole
from jacob where he says that he's a
wolf in a human body so he knows that
jacob still believes he's a canine does
not want to express it in front of
others the doctor whispers not to worry
because it helped him stop having those
thoughts about himself but we see that
the boy is very thoughtful about it
that night jacob is restless and looks
out a window while trying not to
begins to walk in hopes of distraction
but he ends up posed on all fours as if
to howl he reaches a window opens it and
starts to howl and we notice he begins
to feel much better for freeing himself
that way
at the same time another girl arrives
behaving like a feline and tells them to
shut up where they'll find him
shortly after a guard enters both
teenagers have to hide
the girl takes jacob outside where he
vents by howling loudly the next day the
patient's relatives go to visit them and
jeremy's mother gets upset with dr mann
since he's made her son get injured by
climbing that tree
the doctor quickly convinces her that
these methods do not compare to the
cruelty that will happen outside if
they're not fully cured
so he takes her to talk in private later
while they're in session some boys with
horse masks throw the body of a dog at
them while they call them freaks
they quickly evacuate while the doctor
tries to catch the criminals
jacob takes the dog in his hands
the feline girl arrives and together
they take the body outside dig a hole
and leave it inside since they felt bad
about what happened to the poor little
animal
that night jacob and the girl talked
about their lives we find out that the
feline has lived there since she was a
little girl
jacob also tells his story saying that
it's really hard living like this
and they must comfort each other
the next day dr mann wants judith to
jump out a window and fly since she
thinks she's a parrot
the girl screams scared since she knows
that she can get hurt even though she
insists she's a bird
the doctor keeps pressing her even more
to jump and fly
breaking her spirit
the desperate girl screams that she's a
human girl and they leave her alone
the doctor feels comforted since he's
advanced a little with her
at night jacob begins to walk through
the corridors on all fours
he runs into the feline girl and they
leave the place calmly
on the roof they begin to play
but after a few minutes the feline tells
them to stop since jacob is playing very
rough
the next day the doctor forces them to
smile and laugh aloud to highlight that
human side they still have inside
although it's very difficult for them to
do so
later they start bothering the boy again
so this time jacob can't stand it and
goes to help
but his animal instinct wakes up
growling at the boy then he looks little
boy as if he were his prey so the doctor
stops him and takes him away
in dr mann's office jacob has warned
that no other behavior like that will be
accepted and there will be serious
consequences saying that his parents are
aware of everything the next day is
graduation so several teenagers leave
the place since they've been cured and
can return to their normal lives with
their parents
later the doctor takes jacob to a wolf
that's locked in a cage while asking him
if he really wants to be like that
pathetic and hairy beast since men are
the superior race in the world to catch
canines like that one for fun
jacob only sees the sadness in the
wolf's eyes
then when the doctor tries to take away
from the cage jacob clings to stay with
the animal and they both begin to howl
understanding each other when the doctor
sees this behavior he quickly pulls
jacob away
while the wolf inside the cage howls
the doctor locks him in another cage
telling him that he's not a wolf but a
boy who's sick and repeats this phrase
over and over again
later the feline girl goes to a cell and
tries to talk to him
but jacob seems very affected since he
does not pay much attention to her
she lets him know that she was also kept
locked up in that cage for a long time
at that moment jacob approaches her and
they begin to smell each other closely
and end up consoling each other by
holding hands
the next day the doctor takes jacob to
another cage in which there's a man
who's behaving much like a lion
in the end he could no longer become
conscious as a human so in his mind he
stayed like an animal forever
the doctor tells jacob that he'll let
him sleep in his room like the others
but he has to consider what happened to
that man and be careful about his wolf
instincts since he might never be the
same again
and he would forget his family
and they would forget him
that night jacob dreams of being free in
the forest and rejoicing among the earth
then he wakes up and goes to the roof
where he drinks water from the floor
the doctor arrives saying that he warned
him and did not listen so he also had
him to go back to his room
jacob is very upset so the more they
yell at him the more he gets furious and
from one moment to another he starts to
growl and ends up attacking the doctor
the cat girl arrives and tells him to
calm down
so he leaves the doctor and they go back
inside the next day the doctor takes
jacob back to the cage but this time
with a chain and gag
so that he doesn't hurt anyone else
later rufus relatives arrive
bringing him back since he really wasn't
behaving like a normal person
they leave him hospitalized again while
he urinates in his pants the parents
leave and when the doctor sees their
left alone he begins to mistreat rufus
telling him that he misbehaved while the
feline girl listens to everything and is
very sad for rufus that night the girl
puts on makeup to look more like a cat
then she goes to where jacob is takes
off her clothes in front of him and they
start touching each other the next day
jacob tells the girl that they have to
escape from that place at the same time
dr angela enters and gets scared when
she sees them together
shows he takes the feline girl away
while the boy remains upset in his cage
later the other patients are in a dance
session with the doctor while dr mann
takes the opportunity to punish jacob
with electricity so he regrets what he's
done jacob screams reach the other
teenagers and they get upset and start
running away from the doctor
more staff are allowed to contain them
but they defend themselves as best they
can dr man comes out and reassures them
all making fun of each of their
conditions
and all the teenagers end up locked in
cages later the feline girl steals the
keys to the cages goes to rescue jacob
they leave the facilities although the
girl regrets it and decides to stay
since she's afraid to walk outside
and ask jacob to do the same
the alarm sounds in the facility and
jacob decides to run away alone
we see the boy howling very happily to
be free as prompted by his animal
instinct the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best drama and horror
movies
thanks for watching